today we are taking a look at the first
new mac devices with the brand new m1
chip
we have the new macbook air the macbook
pro 13 inch
and the mac mini m1 is apple's first
chip in their family of chips that are
being built in-house that will slowly
over the next two years replace intel
but don't worry if you do have an intel
mac or you're buying one right now
it will still be supported but what this
new m1 chip means
is that apple will now be able to
optimize for smaller and more power
efficient macs
so first let's start with the macbook
air this has a starting price of 9.99 or
if you have an education discount you
can get it for 8.99 so this macbook can
be configured with 16 gigs of ram
a new 2 terabyte solid state drive that
is two times faster than before
it'll have five times faster graphics
3.5 times faster cpu and up to 18 hours
of battery life the display is a 13.3
inch p3 wide color retina display
it also has improved facetime camera and
it also has thunderbolt and usb4
all while being completely silent there
are no
fans in this thing that's one of the
things that i'm really looking forward
to testing out
how silent are you it's just so small
it's soaked oh
wow
what the heck
that was shocking he's talking about
it's doing it's doing its thing it's
doing its thing oh my gosh the setup the
setup
it's crazy that i do so much with tech
and still every time i open something
anything it's just such an exciting
experience
getting a new device just always makes
me even more excited for the future even
though i know that i should be enjoying
the thing that is in front of me right
now
these m1 macs are setting up the future
of mac hardware as we know it is
changing
everything also in the box we've got our
charger
look at this little baby charging brick
my 16 inch macbook
the charging brick is so massive less
power consumption
means smaller charging bricks means all
around good time
i love that we are instantly oh my god
look at this is this not the most
innovative top-down experience
you guys have ever seen i love that the
first screen
is about accessibility apple has been
doing so much
as far as accessibility is concerned and
the fact that this is the first screen
that you were greeted with
is such a step in the right direction oh
you want me to set up touch id
all right so i cannot wait until
they integrate face id into their
macbooks which i feel like
is probably coming very soon especially
because they're now
building these m1 chips in-house and
they're able to store so much more
on these devices as far as like security
it'll be here before we know it
i have faith and if i'm wrong well i'm
wrong i don't care i don't mind being
wrong like a snappy
super snap like look at this look at
this snappy let's open something let's
open up music
very fast podcasts
very fast i do plan on going more in
depth in each one of these devices but
this is kind of just a little unboxing
and a first look
so macbook air check
next up maybe let's go with the mac mini
shall we
the mac mini has a starting price of
6.99 which is
one of the least expensive macs you can
currently buy now it doesn't come with a
display a keyboard or a mouse
but still you're getting a mac for 6.99
so if you already have a keyboard
already have a display i already have a
mouse
you've got a pretty great deal here
you're going to be getting a three times
faster cpu
with an a core gpu for six times faster
graphics it has ethernet usb4 and
thunderbolt hdmi 2.0 this also has
pro display xdr support so if you happen
to have apple's
6 000 monitor you will be able to take
full advantage of it
oh wow look man the mac mini is just so
cool like it's just a small little just
compact powerful beast i feel like the
mac mini
is going to be really great for people
who are kind of
realizing that work from home is
now just going to be called work like
you're just working
being able to connect this to a full
display being able to have
all of that power inside of this little
device which also looks incredible like
i like the fact that they decided to go
with this silver color
for this mac mini this time around
[Music]
oh there you freaking are
what else we have in here oh
a single power adapter this is very
small
here's the previous mac mini this is the
more graphite color
it is interesting though because this
has four
usbc thunderbolt ports and this new one
only has
two i was also hoping that they would
put a 10
gigabit ethernet port but this they
didn't which
i feel like a lot of people do use these
as render farms or as networking devices
so that would have sort of made some
sense definitely it would have been nice
if they would have been able to still
put four ports on here in the back but
obviously this one
is just thunderbolt 3. so we are getting
that pro display xdr support
and faster read write speeds with these
but i will definitely be testing this
out further
so let me know if there's anything that
you guys would like me to test out with
this
just leave it in the comments below so
next up we have the new
macbook pro 13 inch now this has 2.8
times
faster cpu five times faster gpu and the
longest battery life
ever on a mac they said that you can get
over 17 hours of wireless web browsing
and 20 hours of video playback
that's a lot of time if you really think
about it how much time
does this mean for me being able to edit
4k footage
i mean we're gonna figure it out because
maybe i will edit this video on here or
maybe
tyler will be editing this video on this
mac
tbd i'd never used a 13-inch macbook pro
before until the last one that came out
when i was reviewing that one and it was
an incredible experience just that size
and form factor
and the power that you're getting in
such a small device is really
really exciting and that's why i'm even
more excited about this now i don't
necessarily travel as much as i used to
so having this as my everyday device is
probably not as realistic as it was
before but what's cool is this is
very very powerful and you can also
connect this to a display so i think
that's where it kind of comes in it's
like do you want to be paying more for a
laptop or do you just want to get a mac
mini
connect it to a display and just be done
with it
oh i'd say this is a thick boy
but it's really not but in comparison to
the air
maybe
hello welcome to my home make yourself
comfortable please take your shoes off
at the door
oh i gotta stop talking to my devices
when they're not turned on because
can't even answer me usb-c cable
a little bit bigger of a charging brick
for our more powerful machine
this doesn't have an apple logo on it i
mean it does but like this one has like
a nice little
cut out matte logo it's fine i'm not mad
just never noticed it before
auto on auto on auto on holy moly
you beautiful baby i don't like
assigning gender
to my devices but i can't help it i just
sometimes do
what a snappy snappy little device
did you know that the sound of snapping
your fingers is not actually the action
of
snapping the sound is actually your
finger
hitting the palm of your hand
my entire life changed when i found that
out
why why is that the image you decided
that i wanted that's like a little
cactus that's what you that's what you
chose for me
hey open the documents folder hey what
does the rest of my day look like
you guys are basically
the same freaking size you're
you're friends you're best friends
god this is so thin it's shocking how
thin this is i know one of the biggest
questions that a lot of people are
having especially if you're not
incredibly tech savvy is which one
would be right for me i think it just
really comes down to what are you going
to be using these devices for
obviously the 13 inch mac pro it's a
more powerful machine so if there is a
chance that you are going to be doing
more processor intensive things like
editing high resolution photos or video
then it
really is a no brainer that the mac pro
is the way to go but that's not the take
away
from how powerful they were able to make
this air and i am so excited
to really get a chance to test this out
so here you guys have it these
are the first devices with the brand new
apple m1 chip
i'm so excited about the future and i
know i'm trying to just
be present and enjoy what we have right
now but this is really a step
in an incredible direction for apple and
i'm very excited to test these out
further
and really just see what we can push the
limits to on all three of these
if you guys are new here welcome to my
channel thank you so much for watching
until the end of this video make sure
you subscribe and hit the bell so you'll
be notified when i post a new video i
have a lot more fun content coming up
for you guys so
i will uh i guess i'll just stop talking
and
see you in the next one bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
baby